AstraZeneca may be able to help.
>> Tucker: AMERICA HAS
EXPERIENCED A RAPID INFLATION
ENGENDERS.
AT ONE POINT, BIOLOGISTS WERE
ALLOWED TO DETERMINE WHAT
BIOLOGY WAS AND THERE WERE TWO,
MALE AND FEMALE.
NOW THERE IS A GENDER, BY
GENDER, PERJURE, HE DRUG, WE
COULD GO ON
FOREVER.
NOT EVERYONE AGREES, SOME PEOPLE
BELIEVE IN SCIENCE AT THEIR
PERIL, IT TURNS OUT.
LAKE INGLE IS ONE OF THEM.
HE'S A STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA AND A RELIGION
CLASS, HE STATED HIS BELIEF THAT
THERE ARE TWO GENDERS BECAUSE
AGAIN, THAT'S BIOLOGY.
HE WAS TOLD HE HAD TO APOLOGIZE
AND FRONT OF THE CLASS WHILE
THEY CRITIQUED HIM.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: YOU HAD THIS
PROFESSOR, ALLISON DOWNEY WHO
WAS SO THREATENED BECAUSE YOU
DISAGREED WITH HER THAT SHE
TRIED TO GET YOU TO SIGN SOME
FORM APOLOGIZING FOR YOUR
UNORTHODOX NOT ALLOWED THOUGHTS
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENED?
>> SHE ASKED THAT I WOULD SIGN A
DOCUMENT COMPLYING WITH HER
ASKING ME TO APOLOGIZE TO THE
CLASS AS WELL AS GIVING HER A
WRITTEN APOLOGY.
SHE ASKED I WOULD STAND IN FRONT
OF THE CLASS IN SILENCE AS I
APOLOGIZED AND THEY WOULD GIVE
ANY COMMENTS ON MY OUTBURST.
>> Tucker: DID SHE SAY WHAT
SPECIFICALLY SHE WAS SO OFFENDED
BY?
>> SHE DIDN'T LIKE THE FACT THAT
I DISAGREED WITH THE SUBJECT
BEING PUSHED IN CLASS, BEING
MORE THAN ONE GENDER, MALE
PRIVILEGE, SYSTEMIC SEXISM AND
MAN'S PLANING
>> Tucker: IS MANSPLAINING A
MEASURABLE THING QUESTION MIKE
WHAT IS THAT?
SPEAKS REALLY.
IT IS NOT MEASURABLE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, IT'S
PROPAGANDA.
WHAT WAS IT THAT YOU SAID
SPECIFICALLY THAT MADE HER SO
MAD?
>> I FIRST REFERENCED THE
ECONOMISTS AND STATED THAT
BIOLOGIST DON'T AGREE THAT THERE
ARE MORE THAN TWO GENDERS, THEY
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE 72
GENDERS OR MORE
ACROSS-THE-BOARD.
MOST.
MOST OF THEM DISAGREE.
SHE DIDN'T APPRECIATE THAT.
>> Tucker: BY CITING THE
LONG-STANDING VIEW OF
BIOLOGISTS, THE HARD SCIENTISTS
ALLISON DOWNEY, SHE'S A
PROFESSOR, SHE TRIED TO GET YOU
TO STAND IN FRONT OF THE CLASS
TO TAKE ABUSE.
DID YOU DO THAT?
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
I WAS SUPPOSED TO COME UP SHE
DIDN'T GIVE ME A CHANCE.
I WAS GIVEN TEN DAYS TO COMPLY,
BUT THE DAY AFTER SHE ASKED THIS
OF ME, SHE DECIDED TO PUSH IT TO
THE UNIVERSITY PROVOST OFFICE TO
THEN HOLD A HEARING WHICH WOULD
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT I COULD BE
ALLOWED IN CLASS PERIOD.
>> Tucker: WHY DO YOU GO TO
THIS SCHOOL?
WHAT ARE YOU GETTING OUT OF THIS
EXACTLY?
>> I INITIALLY WENT FOR
ATHLETICS MY FRESHMAN YEAR, BUT
THAT'S A LONG GONE DREAM NOW.
I'M PRETTY MUCH JUST STUCK HERE.
>> Tucker: I WISH I COULD HIRE
YOU, I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU OR
ANYONE ELSE TO JOIN THE
WORKFORCE.
IT'S NOT WORTH IT.
THIS IS A JOKE.